hello welcome to this video playing the
Jedi ok I played it before once and not
too long ago and not in a galaxy far far
away so what do we get ok so I kind of
delayed um damage damage one if you want
it can also be that they can also call
that the hoopla variation with the tempo
down with a three so I don't mind that
one bit my absolute pad line q in situ
we ok don't want to Luke rookie 8
doesn't make any sense in this position
after d5 and you form let's see i have a
couple of useful nothing outside with
age 6
the purpose of age six is mostly to make
that night mobile and sometimes you get
a good square on age seven this is
actually a case a case of that here
night h7 is interesting um is there a
difference between night 198 huh I'm not
quite sure I think I can both move see
playable the important thing is that
black should try to get an f5 in this
position black should not sit around
here can / should be 3 is not helping
what and in any way in fact it's rather
vulnerable there on that square ok so he
went back to d2 yeah I'm going to take
it i guess on hmm yeah I think I'm
taking an f4 is interesting if he will
replace that move I'd like to prevent it
if possible with 96 is quite clearly not
possible ok so 27 therefore sometimes
can be an issue because of the is six
square but ok it doesn't doesn't seem to
care Queen f50 move let's see maybe i
can trade queens it would be enormously
helpful
okay does it do it okay i'm happy with
frozen trades here oh I of course of
course evil as a weakness I'm happy to
give you that pawn Queen takes now loses
the game simply so he has to take with
the point Queen takes will lose the e4
pawn in the long run problem this is
also not easy maybe he's get this guy
gets some rupee one some play on the
beef i'll check take here rook f8 is
probably going hmm I don't want I don't
want to be one would be eight
no he allows that tray that's that's
excellent just have to attack you for
once more with the night and I can be
very happy about it or do I go here I
wonder about the screw be one move if
this is in fact in fact a problem maybe
I'll go here so they have Queen f7 check
in some cases right but you cannot play
night between be one end and since I can
like i can play 9898 queen bee 796 and
i'm getting an attack with queen and
night I don't believe I don't believe we
can do that I'm always amazed how can
you decide on that in a splat
split-second anyway probably probably
has no choice that might be the case but
it's pretty pretty amazing stuff ok
Knight f6 King f3 I can check there I am
check check check and now takes on g2 or
what is the best one that looks check
pretty decisive
I was thinking night a 34 night you one
chick made or any better I had this one
seems pretty good Bishop doesn't have
exactly many squares
now I'm looking entirely stupid because
I don't see the maid night you one check
King III Queen f3 check still don't see
it
time morning check so where's the mate
where is the bloody made Queen f3 king
be too I don't see a mate them
don't see a checkmate bloody hell that's
not good the eighth point is pretty
quick not threatening a jet
I didn't find them made them can you
believe that obviously you can it's just
check right in front of you check in i
have to almost made her check checkmate
nexim oyster should have been a quicker
made yeah well actually nice display of
some ideas of this opening but TV was
very cooperative with many things um for
example this is very helpfully i have
three tags and so on the thing is that
this is a really bad poem now that can
easily attacked Beasley attacked by
Queen at night and the bishop is not a
defender chat so i was very surprised by
the capture I think he should have gone
here after which I go back and yeah then
we go from here maybe the this this is
something that I was was thinking but he
has to to think about this a little bit
and not just just just play play this
yeah I'm a lot better as if I was
basically doomed after 98 this and this
yeah this is probably using yeah that is
losing anything that scans you much like
that that again I did manage to find a
maid so where's the mate Queen f2 is the
mate it's not exactly difficult taking
this away just keeping them in that cage
491 mate hmm pretty bad check
I mean this is still Winningham but sure
check-check could have made my life a
little bit a little bit easier yeah so
he didn't really try to challenge my set
up there and a possible way to do that
is maybe night to age form trying to
prevent a five this is something that
quite often um um helps wide here 96 is
interesting and now night f5 and the
capture is not a big deal here maybe he
can go away for that sets possible
because my night position but I can
still go back to have six they are Queen
and something like this is okay and
cheesesteaks there should be 386 this by
the way is a position that the the
engine constantly miss evaluates it
gives wide an advantage and white has
nothing and it's one of one of those
cases quite often um the engine does not
yeah correctly evaluate that the d5 pawn
is not a big asset in this kind of
position um yeah and so a lot of that
when when I was writing my book the
engine even has some very funny miss
evaluations where the situation is
completely drawn because of the blocked
nature of the position and still it
gives why to use a real huge advantage
yeah there's still some areas where the
computers don't get anywhere i can i can
give you 11 very funny example um if I
just put this now on the board it's it's
it's not a forced line it doesn't make
it wouldn't be a wouldn't be a perfect
play or anything I just want to show the
basic idea
what kind of position the engine just
not getting what I'm saying this this
kind of this kind of situation here um
it's it's quite funny if you put this on
the board and the position like that
yeah in positions like that okay here
this is this is really very bad because
a for gets lost um how do i how do I put
this on the board ya hear what is
actually really bad and where was that
it was a kind of funny position type now
even even something like that IAM in a
position like that only only black can
be better because there are all those
weaknesses here and in some cases if
things go wrong white will lose one of
the pawn and the engine gives it as
equal and anyway there are a couple of
positions where the computer is not a
not getting not getting it simply and
for example I remember something that
was really weird um what was that a
position where black was even a piece
down there was no way forward for what
because the position is so closed yeah
okay anyway I hope you enjoyed the video
thanks for watching